le deuxième décret concerne la tenue
d'élections générales auxquelles est
aussi simple que ça
et campagne électorale commence toujours
par une visite chez le
lieutenant-gouverneur meilleure des
chances
caméra 3,2 des lancements de campagne il
y en a eu des plutôt austère la
nationalisation d'électricité est une
grande et fructueuse à faire non
seulement pour le bien être matériel du
québec
mais tout autant pour la santé social et
l'avenir national du canada français
d'autres se sont faits dont la joie et
l'allégresse comme les créditistes en 73
[Musique]
j'ai dépanné
mais le message combatif ou mobilisateur
reprend parfois vite ses droits
allende au chili pour sauver le régime
renversé système qu'on sait système
quand ce système quand ces systèmes
laurent system32 bonnes volontés salaire
au fil du temps les campagnes
électorales se sont adaptés aux progrès
pour la campagne de 1985 c'est le fameux
ordinateur qui allie tout changer pour
mieux fichés et contacter les électeurs
et puis les fameuses chansons à slogan
[Musique]
parlons-en des slogans plus est court
plus c'est facile a martelé comme
pauline marois l'a déterminé mon équipe
elle est déterminée je le suis aussi
très déterminé trois mots c'est bien
aussi
merci plus que ça ça se complique
soyons solide votons solidaires nous
convions oui soyons lucides votants
solidaire des idées des promesses des
messages de mobilisation
tout y passe oui si la combo le plus
important c'est le combat de ma vie
d'autres demeurent réalistes où on voit
cette élection alors comme une occasion
importante et incontournable de
croissance pour la dq il reste que plus
souvent qu'autrement le recours à la
formule assassine et intemporel on parle
de changement mais oui les changements
c'est plutôt l'imposture et la grande
illusion un coup de barre à droite est
donné on peut plus attendre il faut
relancer québec ça suffit on est tanné
faut enfin s'occuper des vraies affaires
et les critiques de bilan sont toujours
privilégiées il a permis que des hauts
dirigeants du parti libéral puissent
profiter des achats de la société des
alcools pour faire des profits indus le
taux de chômage au québec flotte entre 9
ou 10% deux fois le niveau de l'ontario
ce parti leurs présentement
on a proposé
[Musique]
bref au fil du temps les politiciens
changent mais les stratégies sont somme
toute assez semblables et l'objectif
reste identique vous convaincre vous les
électeurs ici frédéric arnould radio
canada montréal
[Musique]